Amigos, puede que no se hable mucho de este
país, pero lo cierto es que Indonesia importa
mucho más de lo que te imaginas.
Más de 250 millones de personas, la mitad
menores de 30 años, convierten a Indonesia…
en el país musulmán con más habitantes
del planeta.
Pero… no solo eso.
Indonesia, amigos, es también uno de los
países más complicados.
Veréis, me explico.
Indonesia es un enorme archipiélago compuesto
por más de 17.000 islas que se extiende,
atentos, de punta a punta por más de 5.000km,
aproximadamente la distancia que separa Londres...
de Afganistán.
Con este dato ya nos podemos imaginar la enorme
variedad de etnias, culturas e idiomas que
nos podemos encontrar en este país.
Y también las enormes diferencias sociales.
Por ejemplo, mientras los ciudadanos de Yakarta
son casi adictos a Twitter, una quinta parte
de la población ni siquiera tiene acceso
a la electricidad.
("La diversidad de Indonesia no es sólo geográfica
y cultural; diferentes grupos están viviendo
básicamente en diferentes puntos de la historia
humana, todos al mismo tiempo.
Viajar desde Yakarta a las islas Molucas es
como retroceder en el tiempo.)
Elizabeth Pisani.
Ya os podéis imaginar lo rematadamente difícil
que puede resultar gestionar un país así.
Un país, en el que por cierto, pasó una
buena parte de su infancia, Barack Obama.
Si, tal cual como lo escucháis, la madre
de Obama se casó en 1965 con un ciudadano
indonesio y 2 años más tarde se fueron a
vivir a Jakarta.
(«Siento un gran afecto por la gente de aquí.
Mi hermana es medio indonesia y mi madre trabajó
aquí mucho tiempo».
Barack Obama.)
Pero… vale, puede que algunos de vosotros
estéis pensando…pero Enrique ¿Por qué
diantre debería importarme Indonesia?
¿Qué tiene de especial este país?
Pues vereis amigos, a pesar de todas las dificultades,
la economía indonesia ha crecido bastante
en los últimas décadas … y aunque
pueda sorprendernos, Indonesia se convertirá
en unos años en la mayor potencia musulmana
del planeta.
Y eso es algo que tiene muchas implicaciones,
sociales, políticas y también económicas:
(“Notas el cambio hasta en la forma de vestir.
La edad media está en torno a los 29-30 años;
esas personas jóvenes que han salido al mercado,
que están mejor formadas, constituyen una
clase media urbana con un enorme dinamismo,
y ese dinamismo es lo que va a cambiar este
país.
El turismo está creciendo gracias a su demanda;
los centros comerciales viven del consumo
local; se vende más de un millón de vehículos
al año…”, Carlos Gastón, representante
del BBVA en Indonesia.)
Bien, creo que ya te puedes imaginar
por qué Indonesia debería importarnos más
de lo que parece.
Pero antes de echar un vistazo a lo que está
ocurriendo, veamos un poquito de historia.
LA INDEPENDENCIA
La historia de Indonesia, de Indonesia como
país, ha tenido 2 protagonistas principales:
Sukarno y Suharto.
Veréis, Indonesia es un país bastante nuevo…
no fue hasta 1949 cuando consiguió su independencia
de los Países Bajos.
Sí, tal cual como lo escucháis, Indonesia
no fue una colonia británica ni francesa,
sino una colonia holandesa.
Y no penséis que conseguir la independencia
fue coser y cantar… para nada.
Me explico, Sukarno fue un importante líder
de la resistencia contra el dominio colonial.
En 1927 fundó el Partido Nacionalista Indonesio
con este lema: “Una nación, Indonesia;
un pueblo, el indonesio; un idioma, el Bahasa
Indonesia”.
(Claro que… como os podéis imaginar, todas
estas ideas no le hacían ninguna gracia a
las autoridades holandesas, así que Sukarno
fue perseguido, detenido y finalmente recluido
en una especie de exilio en Sumatrá.
Una reclusión forzosa, amigos, de la que
fue liberado en la II Guerra Mundial por las
tropas japonesas cuando ocuparon indonesia.
Los japoneses se aliaron de alguna forma con
los nacionalistas indonesios para poder controlar
más fácilmente el país.)
Pues bien, el caso es que dos días después
de la rendición de Japón en agosto de 1945,
Sukarno declaró la independencia de Indonesia….
una declaración de independencia que no fue
reconocida por las autoridades holandesas.
Lejos de ellos trataron de restablecer su
poder… mediante la fuerza.
Comenzó así la llamada “Revolución Nacional”
que duró 4 años y que, amigos, fue muy,
pero que muy sangrienta.
(“Holanda investigará su oscuro pasado
colonial en Indonesia”.)
Para que os hagáis una idea, se calcula que
en apenas 4 años, más de 100.000 indonesios
y 5.000 soldados holandeses perdieron la vida.
Y así fue, como finalmente en 1949, tras
mucho, demasiado sufrimiento, las autoridades
holandesas aceptaron y reconocieron la Independencia
de Indonesia.
DOS DICTADURAS.
Amigos, que Indonesia logrará la independencia
no quiere decir que la libertad llegará al
país, para nada.
Durante los siguientes 18 años, Sukarno dirigió
Indonesia de una forma cada vez más autoritaria,
bajo un modelo que se conoció como la “democracia
dirigida”.
[Y, amigos, palabra, cada vez que se lo pone
un adjetivo al término democracia suele ser
todo menos democracia.]
El caso es que durante este tiempo se produjeron
todo tipo de problemas: el país era muy,
muy pobre, la economía no funcionaba y se
produjeron todo tipo de rebeliones y conflictos:
étnicos, de autodeterminación, un conflicto
con Malasia y muy especialmente con el Partido
Comunista Indonesio - el primer partido comunista
de Asia, por cierto - que con el apoyo de
China y la Unión Soviética era cada vez
más importante en el país.
(Veréis, Sukarno aunque no era considerado
como un líder comunista si fue un lider de
corte socialista al que no le importó acercarse
a la China de Mao y que incluso recibió apoyo
de la Unión Soviética.
Algo que no evitó que el Partido Comunista
Indonesio quisiera hacerse con el poder.)
Pues bien, en 1965 se produjo un importante
choque.
Mandos del ejército vinculados al Partido
Comunista prepararon un golpe de estado…
que no funcionó.
Este suceso desencadenó una tremenda represión
contra el partido comunista que le costó
la vida a cientos de miles de personas y que
fue aprovechada, por el jefe del ejército,
Suharto para hacerse con el poder con el apoyo
de Estados Unidos.
Durante las siguientes 3 décadas Suharto
dirigió con mano de hierro el país.
Con el apoyo de Washington puso en marcha
algunas medidas de apertura económica que
tuvieron bastante éxito e hicieron que el
crecimiento se disparará.
(Sin embargo la violencia del estado, la represión
política y la corrupción estaban tremendamente
generalizadas.
Y cuando a finales de los 90, se produjo la
crisis asiática la economía indonesia se
derrumbó.
La rupia perdió, atentos, el 80% de su valor
contra el dólar y la pobreza se multiplicó
por cuatro.
Así que… con este panorama, el general
Suharto se vio obligado a dejar el poder.)
Tras casi 50 años de independencia y dictadura…
la democracia en Indonesia tenía una oportunidad.
Y finalmente tras muchos conflictos, porque
en este país, los conflictos son constantes,
en 2004 se celebraron las primeras elecciones
libres.
(Desde la caída de Suharto, Indonesia ha
vivido un periodo de cambios, apertura política,
descentralización y una política económica
más abierta al mundo…. aunque aun con muchas
restricciones.)
Pues bien, el caso es que en 2014 ganó las
elecciones el actual presidente, Joko Widodo,
popularmente conocido como Jokowi y calificado
como el Barack Obama Indonesio.
(Jokowi prometió liberalizar mucho más el
país, impulsar el crecimiento por encima
del 7% cada año y sentar las bases para que
Indonesia se convirtiese en todo una potencia
económica y política, la mayor potencia
musulmana del mundo.)
En ese momento, amigos, las expectativas estaban
por las nubes y en los medios internacionales
se hablaba de Indonesia como el país del
futuro.
Sin embargo, desde entonces algunas cosas
han... cambiado.
Atentos.
JOKO WIDODO: UN PRESIDENTE ENTRE DOS MUNDOS
La llegada de Joko supuso toda
una revolución, un gran soplo de aire fresco.
Jokowi fue el primer candidato ajeno a las
elites militares y políticas
en hacerse con el Gobierno.
Las redes sociales, como Facebook, Twitter
o esta plataforma YouTube, jugaron un papel
clave.
Y lo cierto es que el nuevo presidente empezó
con buen pie en su plan por lograr que Indonesia
se convierta en un país mucho más competitivo.
Desde su llegada al poder, entre otras medidas,
Jokowi ha reducido y eliminado muchos subsidios
y ha destinado ese dinero, unos 40.000 millones
de dólares a tratar de solucionar uno de
los grandes problemas que el país tiene a
día de hoy: la falta de infraestructuras.
Algo que hace que transportar mercancías
entre las islas del país sea, fijaos, más
caro que importar un contenedor desde Europa.
Y no solo eso, el Presidente también ha puesto
en marcha varios paquetes para reducir la
burocracia y la regulación que…. es otro
gran problema.
(La regulación y la burocracia indonesia
son tan pesadas que por ejemplo si una empresa
como Inditex quisiera abrir un nuevo Zara en
Jakarta no podría hacerlo directamente,
tiene que hacerlo a través de franquiciados locales.
Además, muchos sectores están cerrados a
la inversión extranjera y el gobierno tiene
un peso enorme.
Las grandes constructoras, las industrias
aeronáuticas, los astilleros y muchas empresas
de tecnologías de la información siguen
siendo empresas estatales.)
Además, Jokowi está impulsando también
la apertura de zonas económicas especiales
para el turismo y la industria; y ha puesto
en marcha un modelo de seguro médico que
ha dado cobertura a más de la mitad de la
población.
Suena bien ¿Verdad?
Pues, amigos, esperad un momento… porque
a pesar de todo, los cambios están siendo
más lentos de lo que el presidente había
prometido y más lentos de lo que el país
necesita;
(Por ello, aunque la inversión extranjera
ha crecido, las tasa de crecimiento, están
siendo más bajas de lo esperado.)
Pero… desde luego esto no es el mayor problema,
ni lo que probablemente le cueste la reelección
a este presidente.
El gran problema es que en los últimos años
se han producido brotes claros de fundamentalismo
religioso.
¿UNA POTENCIA ISLÁMICA MODERADA?
Durante años, se ha presentado a
Indonesia como un especie de modelo, un país
mayoritariamente musulmán que reconoce la
libertad religiosa, un país cada vez más
abierto al mundo y donde las mujeres participan
activamente en la vida política.
“El Islam tradicionalmente moderado de Indonesia
es realmente una inspiración para el mundo”.
Mike Pence, Vicepresidente de los Estados
Unidos.
De hecho, así es como el gobierno indonesio
se presenta al mundo.
“Indonesia es la tercera democracia más
grande del mundo.
Y también tenemos la mayor población musulmana
del mundo.
Esto demuestra que la democracia y el Islam
no son incompatibles.
Joko Widodo.
Sin embargo, durante los últimos años se
ha producido un incremento bastante importante
del radicalismo religioso.
Es algo que están denunciado organizaciones
como Amnistía Internacional o Human Rights Watch.
Y motivos, la verdad, no faltan:
(por ejemplo el pasado año el Consejo Indonesio
de Ulamas, la mayor autoridad religiosa del
país, vino a defender que los cristianos
y otros no creyentes no deberían tener cargos
políticos en las zonas de mayoría musulmana,
es decir, en la inmensa mayor parte del país.
Por otro lado, el gobernador de Yakarta y
estrecho aliado del presidente Jokowi, un
cristiano de ascendencia china conocido como
Ahok ha sido condenado por blasfemia al insinuar
que la política debería dejar a un lado
la religión.)
Y además, en los últimos años el discurso
de los partidos islamistas se ha endurecido
mucho.
Sin ir más lejos este mismo año están proponiendo
cambiar el código penal para perseguir de
forma más dura las relaciones fuera del matrimonio
y entre parejas del mismo sexo e ilegalizar,
incluso, la convivencia de parejas solteras.
Ojo, de momento Indonesia sigue siendo por
lo general un país relativamente moderado
y la inmensa mayor parte de la población
apoya una democracia abierta e incluso la
libertad religiosa… pero todo apunta a que
en las elecciones de 2019 los islamistas tienen
muchas opciones de llegar al poder.
E insisto, estamos hablando de una futura potencia
que puede darnos muchas alegrías… o muchos
quebraderos de cabeza.
Veréis, si las reformas continúan, Indonesia será
un mercado enorme . Por ejemplo, se estima
que en 2030 el consumo de las clase media
indonesia será muy superior incluso al de
Alemania.
Y además si gana la moderación religiosa
su influencia en el mundo musulmán va a ser
cada vez mayor.
Así que creo que a todos nos conviene que
las cosas en Indonesia marchen por buen camino.
Pero ahora, turno para ti, ¿Crees que hay
que apoyar a Indonesia para favorecer a los
moderados?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo dale
a like.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima